تراجعت الثقة بعلماء الطب ومراكز السيطرة على
الأمراض منذ أن كان من الممكن تجنب ذلك
بشكل جيد ، يجب أن أقول أولاً وقبل كل شيء أنه
كان هناك الكثير من
المعلومات المضللة المضللة وهناك أشخاص
استمروا في ذلك وليس من
علماء مرموقين ومسؤولي الصحة العامة
ولكن في الوقت نفسه ، أعتقد أيضًا
أن مؤسسة الصحة العامة
قد ارتكبت بعض الأخطاء غير القسرية ،
بما في ذلك على سبيل المثال عدم
الاعتراف بالقدر الذي يجب أن نتخيله
أن العلم يتطور وعندما
يتغير العلم وتظهر بيانات جديدة ،
يجب أيضًا تغيير توصياتنا كما
أعتقد  كان بإمكان مركز السيطرة على الأمراض القيام
بعمل أفضل في شرح الأساس المنطقي وراء
تغييراتهم وأعتقد أيضًا أنه
لم يكن علينا أن نتسرع في رفض
بعض الفرضيات التي
تبين أنها صالحة بالفعل على سبيل المثال ، فإن
المناعة الطبيعية هي في الواقع شيء ولكني أعتقد
ذلك  كان هناك خوف في البداية من أنه إذا
تحدثنا عن المناعة الطبيعية ، فقد
يثني الناس عن التطعيم
ولكن في الواقع في عدم الصدق
على الرغم من أنه كان لسبب وجيه هو
محاولة تطعيم الناس ، ما زلت
أعتقد أن انتهى الأمر بقراءة عدم الثقة
لأن الناس اعتقدوا  أنت لست
صريحًا معي بشأن هذا
الشيء الوحيد الذي يجعلني أثق بك في الآخرين الذين
تعرفهم أنني أحب الرد على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
في الوقت الفعلي ، فأنا غير مجهز بأي
شيء أتناوله في covid ولدي
خبير فيك ، لذلك
أعطتني كاثرين شيئًا وأستطيع إشراك الدكتور وين في
الرد عليه ، ما الذي لدينا على ما يرام نحن
بحاجة إلى احتضان حيث أخطأ الخبراء في أن
أطفالنا لم يكونوا في خطر أبدًا
مقارنة بالمسنين أو أولئك الذين لديهم
شروط مسبقة بحجم واحد
نهج يناسب الجميع تسبب في ضرر جسيم لا يمكن إصلاحه
مرة أخرى يحتاج الخبراء إلى تبني هذا وليس
إنكاره والدفاع عنه ، فهذا ليس موجهًا
إليك بالضرورة ولكن ما هو رأيك
في ذلك
أعتقد أن المشكلة هي أننا نستمر في
قول اتبع العلم وبالطبع
أنا  نتفق على اتباع العلم والاستناد إلى
الأدلة في قراراتنا ،
لكن المشكلة هي أن العلم وحده
لن يقدم لنا الإجابات
على سبيل المثال ، على سبيل المثال ، حتى لو كنا نعلم في
البداية أن إغلاق المدارس
سيؤدي إلى هذا الضرر الكبير للأطفال ولكن
أيضًا في البداية خاصةً قبل أن
نصل إلى هذه المستويات من المناعة العالية من
التطعيم والعدوى قبل أن يكون
صحيحًا أن إغلاق المدارس ربما
يقلل من مستوى الانتقال وربما
يكون قد أنقذ الأرواح ، ولكن إذا كانت لديك هذه
البيانات نفسها ، فسيصل الأشخاص المختلفون
إلى استنتاجات مختلفة و
أعتقد في الواقع أن الكثير مما
حدث في ثقة الناس
لمسؤولي الصحة العامة هو أننا نواصل
القول اتبع العلم كما لو كانت هناك
إجابة واحدة صحيحة ليست كل شيء
عن المقايضات. الصحة العامة
معقدة للغاية إنها حقًا دقيقة
وكلما استطعنا الاعتماد على هذا
الفارق الدقيق والتحدث عن المفاضلات ، كلما زاد
قدرتنا على نقل الحقيقة الفعلية إلى
مدى تعقيد هذا الموقف برمته